jede runde 25
über die auftauchenden fallen über die
einwände springen ist der hat die runde
gewonnen
und nebenbei gibt es um das ganze noch
etwas vom schwierigkeitsgrad
hallo und herzlich willkommen zu einer
runde super holländer wohl in minecraft
das ist so ein minigame von knoxville
und wir spielen das zusammen mit herr
bergmann hallo hallo also ich hab mein
sound ausgemacht ist ein mensch jetzt
zusammen mit sturer verdient und wir
haben uns gedacht komm sag thema was wir
uns gedacht haben was wir für drei
runden spielen
wir haben drei und vor eine einfache
runde dass man kann verschiedene
schwierigkeitsgrade einstellen einfach
mittel hart und jede dieser runde 25
die auftauchenden fallen über die runde
gewonnen
und nebenbei gibt es um das ganze noch
etwas vom schwierigkeitsgrad
also es geht halt darum dass so die
wende kommen und man muss da durch
gesamten genau da kriegen wir super hin
okay was als idee aber wir machen nicht
last man standing weil dann ist alles
mit lava und dann wenn man einmal runter
fällt wegen fehlern ist man direkt raus
und das ist blöd ist einfach völlig
gewalttätig leute jetzt bleibt aber
ruhig hier
nicht genau was sie lasst uns loslegen
wie war das denn jetzt kommen die sie
schon ausgewählt
wir haben ein team casual dann machen
wir hier 25
ihr findet den link übrigens dazu in der
beschreibung falls das selber spielen
will statt game geschlagen
teamcenter teams ist mir ein springen
eigentlich doch es gibt teams ihr seid
alle gegen mich stark ist dass sie
vielleicht oder wir machen gleich
schwere teams oder wir wollen das mache
ich finde ich weiß ich nicht ich mehr zu
spontan gesagt da vor der aufnahme ist
abgemacht stimmt wir hatten für einen
teenager sondern jetzt ist alles gut
doch gerade hat mit sieglos wenn das
ganze generiert wird ein bisschen diese
einblendung so einfach weglassen wo sie
ja mal sagen für dieses wie hier das
auch so bleiben
das ist richtig
ich habe einfach versucht den habe ich
ja eben schon mal warten weiter nach
hinten
ganz kurzfristig leute fragen was
rechtens ist ein scoreboard ihr wählt
das motto bis 25 und wer zuerst diese 25
erreicht hat quasi gewonnen und das
jetzt noch easy und dann gibt es gleich
noch medium und hart und ich frage mich
ob zehn grad noch im channel ist ich
weiß gar nicht ob ich bin runter
gefallen das sieht nicht gut aus für
titel sind kein problem
ein bisschen wegdrücken könnte zumindest
was bitte ist es wirklich der hier auch
noch drauf klettern
studio im kindergartenalter hört sich
als wären sich zwei fahrer und ich komme
ich ja auch gar nicht bewegen ist das
okay sie alle vor das ist einmalig
wieder oben richtig rita dabei
du bist du bist einfach zu breit für
diese löcher die da immer sind aber
durch geschlossen
ich habe sogar auch schon auf zehn
gestellt ich habe sie auf 2 aber wir
fest dass man so was machen wir jetzt 25
team hardcore kommen wir mal wieder free
for all
vielleicht kann man am ende ganz am ende
noch mal eine runde teams machen
eine erste runde damit geschlagen
deshalb war es für mich ja das stimmt
haben sie eine google direkt vorbei
einfach nach ein paar sekunden gemacht
jetzt hier nicht weil wenn man das auf
die hat dann sieht man trotzdem durch
passiert ist natürlich die nervosität
groß
nein nein
wie soll man das denn dann komme ich
dann mein gott sie sollte man die
punkterunde hier gerade die blockierer
für das fast doppelt so viel wie ich
mache alles aber der film ist einfach zu
gut für uns auf jeden fall müssen nicht
immer alle knöpfe drücken
laut taylor gruber das ist gerade
abgespielt
das ist schon ein anderes level gespielt
der geht noch wie schwer es war wieder
durch gekommen ein richtiges springen so
wie sie sind ein pinker blöcke drin
ich verstehe dass hier immer noch nicht
irgendwie ist natürlich jetzt anders
wohl so glaube ich das toll
das tor durch gekommen ist dann glaube
ich immer wenn kleinere gott oh mein
gott ich habe richtig hoffnung gemacht
dass hier noch was reizt aber jetzt ist
die hoffnungen geweckt
ich war gerade wieder oben habe ich hier
wiederum geben
ja ich gerade werde ich jetzt auch jetzt
hier noch untergeschossen alltag
reagiert das gut gemacht bis heute
ich bin aber nicht gezielt für mich okay
und zudem recht mit ihnen diese nicht
was ist eigentlich wenn meine rolle
zweimal macht so wieder zurück läuft
irgendwie das funktioniert es geschafft
und alle doppelt punkte bekommen und
nicht was insider barack obama
verstanden sniper über geschirr drüber
gesprochen
an der seite hier die teile sind
dazugekommen
ich bringe immer rüber hinein ich bin
auch man das was solche stürmten wieder
überholt er ist für mich einfach
untergebracht man das wie macht man das
fokusthema ruine die zäune muss nicht so
am rand ist irgendwie dann lacken
ja das ist die bonus man einfach keinen
sinn wird bis 25 spielen ist ja aber das
verrate ich knapp sogar am ende
ich freue mich jetzt noch mal eine
platte wert gewonnen
dann hat alles gewonnen dort zwei sehe
ich hatte ein und ja man gerade dann
bist du der sich geopfert werden noch
fünf für dich gespielt und kehrte dem
karate oder hat hab ja kommt das nicht
dann halt nicht in deinem team ist gut
wir werden euch zu hören jeweils eine
runde gewonnen
colourbox mit dem bin ich damit stolpert
nicht mal begonnen und schon runter das
jetzt kommt schon mal konzentriert
darauf ein event geschaffen und dann
runter
das knapp was man ja ja wir machen das
team battle
doch leben alte zurückgewiesen
weckbecker sie aber er hinterließ
wie könnt ihr denn auch nicht sterben
weil wir noch aus den hp haben aber so
viele hits bekommen die ganze zeit noch
am leben sei
nein ich hab schon passieren sachen
umstellen nein nein nein
nein nein nein
technisch wäre hier ich sagen lukas
visier schlecht eingestellt
gegen die beiden top game hat spaß
gemacht wenn ich finde es lustig wenn
ihr das auch spielen wollt steht es in
der beschreibung und ich würde sagen
jemand das ende war ich schon diesem
wundervollen verpackten anfangen mit dem
nach flash gemacht habe was natürlich
bei jedem von uns da genau wenn ihr
nämlich die sicht von irgendwem anders
sehen wollt dann findet ihr die anderen
teilnehmer an der beschreibung und dann
könnt ihr alle vier videos gleichzeitig
laufen lassen wenn die cool sein
das macht und schickt dann seid ihr
dabei
von meiner seite her würde ich sagen